oh you need to do it like a line instead
of that yeah like that yeah so it needs
to be like it's actually more people can
it just be made love with each other why
do you got to be like that the way
you're drawing it is they [__] it's
like a two German Shepherds made more
Germans but they're all German Shepherds
yours is a pyramid scam
[Music]
hey guess what there's a mom in Utah
okay pregnant
um these moms in Utah are pretty hot
though are they yeah yeah well you've
seen them yeah morning Mormon wives dude
there's like a show there's like there's
like like wives of Salt Lake City or
something they're hot Real Housewives
Are Salt Lake they're like Mormon wise
like and they're hot yeah they're like
super hot super like fit like they're
wearing the Lulu and they like they have
their hair all nice what's going on I'm
just waiting for Ryan to [__] say
something about how they die gruesome oh
they didn't die not at all this is a
celebration of life my friends oh this
is great check it out it's exciting mom
in Utah pregnant uh her and her husband
are excited to uh have this kid and then
they are looking for a name for the baby
and what some people like to do is they
like to go up their own family trees and
kind of find a cool name that's already
existing in their families it hasn't
traveling up the trees
I think like the targaryens always
what because they're related because
like brother sister
like that that is a very short tree yeah
yeah it's up here
they find out they go hey your grandma
and grandpa have the same names as mine
shut the [__] their cousins first and
last song they're probably distant
distance their distance I think they're
third cousins a lot of humans are like
that though but it is blue no that's not
true yeah there's a lot of humans that
are like distant cousin relatives but
like if you look at how One race kind of
formed you could trace it back to like a
small but I think there's like a lot
right how many like well humans came out
of 20 000 people I mean third cousins
and it's blood related that's pretty uh
that's pretty close and they're white
they're white by the way but at least
they know their bloodlines are like pure
you know like because if you that's what
you why did you like say it with such
delectable salivation because you want
your Bloodlines to be well then what
made you go all the way to freaking El
Salvador I just I I shot my shot and I
missed
Salvadorian
I might have no but some people think
like my wife looks a little Asian and I
did too maybe an issue
trying to
but I did up here you wanted to keep
the people in Chinese have sound
Department person yeah that's tough
that's really tough I shot my shot I'm
not really good at it I didn't say I was
good I just you know I shot yeah I got
it got it what the [__] so okay so
they're sitting next to each other as
they're yeah how [__] awful yeah
they're both doing that at the same time
and then they realize like oh what the
heck and then they go we're targaryens
pretty much I don't know what I would do
at that point like are you supposed to
like say well the baby's already made
I no it she's still pregnant oh when the
baby comes out I don't is there a super
high risk I think you're I think you're
good right isn't it isn't it the second
generation that starts to see possible
defects and stuff like that so so let's
say if the uh if the is it great
grandparents I I think it's Grant maybe
it is I'm not sure let me see because
it's because it was like great
grandparents then that means uh the
grandparents great grandparents oh it's
grandparents oh it's close they don't
know each other that well then
no so their first cousin she goes she
goes oh I was like oh look grandpa's
name grandma's name great grandma's name
great great grandma's name all those
were the same on the tree
wait a minute so you're talking about
there's many generations of constant
so they went with the first grandparent
names and they go oh wow coincidence and
then they go great grandparents are like
oh [__] they're the same okay great
great so it's their grandparents where
it finally splits yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and they got confused from there
so it's a wishbone up till that and then
it's just straight right California
Redwood do they share grandparents or do
they share great grandparents they're
sure grandparents okay so out of their
grandparents right that means they're
first cousins because they're their
parents are siblings right or do they
share a pet if they share a parent then
they're [__] brother and sister
they're the best and they didn't know
I grew up here in this house so did I so
they don't share parents so their
parents aren't siblings so they're not
cousins so how did yeah it says their
third cousins but how is that possible
if they share grandparents don't okay so
it's let's see it's the grandparents the
grandparents have four kids yeah this
set of parents produced the girl this
set of parents or uh this this group
produces the boy that's first cousins no
why not
oh yeah that is first card that is first
cousin I'll give you first cousins
yeah when two [__] uh parents and
their brothers siblings they have
children those children are cousins okay
we'll just say that we'll say this for
the sake of the article because this is
just getting too wild the person writing
the article Okay the third cousin is the
key word how they [__] do it we don't
need to do math okay they're just third
cousins but we need to see the trees
some of us need Visions
detectivizing because this is [__]
weird why don't I Google it it says
their third cousin so let's say [__] it
[__] it let's just say right Anthony do
you stay with your significant other no
is it gross you divorce
no no the babies yeah the slow cooker's
on baby you're saying wait you're saying
divorced you're saying no no I'm not
saying divorce I think you gotta stick
it out at them the way that I think
about it is I say let's make a diamond
out of it what does that mean so so it's
like this and then we bring it back down
the Family diner that's gotta be a
triangle you just flip it over the
reason why it matters to me if it's
first cousin or third cousin or whatever
is because the more removed you are the
less of a genetic issue right like for
probability so it's like if they're the
more closer they are like siblings you
have the highest chance of like issues
in pregnancy right so then for me I'm
like well I already spent my life with
this person I married this person I love
this person and if it's far enough
removed then this has been going on in
human history for so [__] long anyway
it's kind of eel for the moment but [__]
it's the same person I think it's ill
for a really long time no it's not yes
it is not [__] your cousins is a new
thing yeah that's true that's what I say
[__] your cousins is a new thing it
is like it's Chic to do that it used to
be it used to be the norm what's our
definition of you think about well the
royal family the Royal just a hundred
years ago we were doing it this is
[__] new [__] I'm saying we like a
hundred years ago is a long no it's not
not if it's been like a thousand years
of us doing it uh you know it's ten
percent like think about all the Royal
the Royals in Europe all the royal
families in Europe are related because
of this reason right they're more
related to each other than they are to
the people that they ruled I know but we
have iPhones now we're like very
sophisticated we don't do [__] like that
anymore you know the better thing to do
is once you find out that happens you
just shut your [__] mouth and you
don't make an article about it I don't
go to the presses about it on the donut
box here we have Anthony's
second cousin first cousin third cousin
that's her Tick Tock post about it okay
let's see what do you got Anthony yeah
what do you got if you had like these
people right they had like a son and a
daughter yeah and let's just assume that
their next Generation they had Sons and
Daughters yeah and then the next and the
next that's when you get to a third
cousin realm so if this sun right here
like went and got together with like
this daughter over here yeah good then
you would be third cousins but still
have a similar grandparent generation
line but it's still really really
confusing if they're same blood look how
far that is that's also slightly
inaccurate because you're considering
the grandparent had a son and daughter
that [__] each other that made more
kids that [__] each other that made no
those are new people
if you draw a family tree like that
you're showing that they all [__] each
other and [__] each other oh you need
to do it like a line instead of that
yeah like that yeah so it needs to be
like it's actually more people can't it
just be made love with each other why do
you gotta be like that
the way you're drawing it is they
[__] it's like a two German Shepherds
made more Germans but they're all German
Shepherd yours is up here
it's cool don't King Shake yeah they all
send 500 up to the top yeah that's just
how to make money and it is 2x2.net
I was like we all
we are
50 years ago but that's different
because some places they still do
because when I'm [__] my cousin it's
different because my cousin might have a
different set of like grandparents you
know your cousins are multi-level
marketing
your cousins are diamond sellers
identical [__] Cousins they're
Reckoning all the cash baby they're
[__] siblings driving pink PT
Cruisers
oh my God so envious
you know I'm so into this [__] family
tree [__] though what I just finished
watching House of dragons and I'm like
how did it get to Daenerys from all
these brother [__] and sister [__]
oh you finished the whole season I
finished yeah this season but then I I
wanted to see like how did it get to the
you know the uh Game of Thrones yeah
Daenerys and someone did a graph of it
and then who got with who and then like
the targaryens do sibling [__] right so
then and then that's why they came I
mean sometimes your siblings hot
a lot of the targaryens are hot
yeah but then if you grew up with them
do you see them as hot that's the real
question the targaryens do that's the
real question I think they're just
playing by a different set of rules back
then you know yeah they're just you just
did it to me baby make but everyone had
like to preserve Royal Blood side fun
yeah if you look at the Lannister side
fun is a really good term well they also
there was perks right one if you like
[__] your your sibling then you'd stay
Royal and then two you would also be
able to control dragons I feel like
that's kind of worth it and it goes back
to my first point you keep the
Bloodlines pure speaking of like royalty
and stuff like that anybody here ever
worn like a king's crown or anything by
any chance I wish
like prom King even
yeah if only we had someone close to
royalty that's not understood was there
a prompt game here here dude this is
this is the worst day of my life it's
not us
is it you guys you guys not me
definitely I'm even going way too cool
any any prom Kings close to the 110 110
and the 210 maybe somewhere like
Monrovia but not really more prestigious
how did they even announce a prom King
this is the war's day like a like a Los
Robles type of
just different streets of Pasadena wait
a minute did you where you want to float
at the Rose Parade I was a royal
princess dude I was like this no they're
okay so we get we have two more before
before it gives us the answer right yeah
two more we're gonna get those two
sarcastic responses yeah yeah yeah what
are the words
he's like damn it those are the rules
he's got two layers of Kevlar and then
the painful truth yeah yeah how old were
you how old were you when it happened
and were you were you expecting it no I
wasn't so it was surprised it was one of
those movie moments don't you have to
make posters and campaign for yourself
oh is that how it wasn't like because if
you did that that's really funny
he paid I didn't even know like that was
I didn't know how they were gonna do it
like I wasn't on my radar at all I just
yeah I think other people pick you right
don't they like someone nominate you
some people felt sorry for me because I
was the loser of the kid and then I got
up there and they dumped blood all over
me they all voted the dumbest dude there
yeah yeah the [__] ugliest one
they're like yeah that's the guy they
did it as a joke
because I rode the short bus to school
[Music]